من جهته شدد نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد قاي
على ان عمليات البحث وانقاذ مستمر حتى اخر
لحظه واكد الطائف في مؤتمر صحفيه اتخاذ كل
التدابير لمواجهه احتمالات انتشار الاوبئه
في المناطق المركوبه من الزلزال
عمليات البحث والانقاذ مستمره ولن نفقد
الامل في العثور على ناجينا حتى اخر لحظه
سنكمل عمليه رفع الانقاذ لتبدا عمليه
اعاده الاعمار كما سيتم دفن الموت في اقرب
وقت ممكن مع مراعاه كل التفاصيل القانونيه
والدينيه
طبعا
من اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد
تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره فرح الزمان
شوقي
تضعين في اخر مستجدات التصريحات السياسيه
كلها تابعنا مؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه
التركي رفقه نظيره اليوناني وكان هناك
ايضا بعد ذلك مؤتمن صحفي وزير الداخليه
سليمان سولو ماذا كان ابرز في تصريحات
اليوم
[موسيقى]
ليس هذا وحسب عبد الصمد يصل ايضا امير قطر
الى تركيا
ليلتقي نظيره التركي وليكن اول زعيم يصل
الى تركيا بعد حلول هذه الكارثه وبعد ان
اجرى معه اتصالا هاتفيا وبعد انشات قطر
جسرا جويا ونقلت مشافي ميدانيه وطواقم
انقاذ عبر سبع طائرات تقريبا هذه الزياره
التي وصفت بانها زياره عمل تاتي كذلك
لتعزيز جهود الاغاثه وعلى جانب ذلك في
السياسه ايضا كما قلت وزير الخارجيه
اليوناني كان قد اجرى جوله تفقديه برفقه
نظيره التركي مولود شاوش اوغلو على
المناطق المتضرره والمنكوبه في الحقيقه هي
زياره يمكن وصفها بالاستثنائيه والتي اتت
بعد الظروف الصعبه ووجود العديد من
الملفات العالقه التي ادت لكثير من
التصعيد والتراشق السياسي بين البلدين في
الفتره الماضيه
درجه ان تشوش شغله اليوم يقول بانه حان
الوقت للتطبيع مع اليونان رغمه وجود
الخلافات بين الطرفين وليؤكد نظيره
اليوناني على ذات الامر ويؤكد بان طاقم
الانقاذ الذي تم ارساله من اثينا ايضا
ساهم بعمليات الانقاذ تحولات كثيره في
الحقيقه على الصعيد السياسي هي ليست
مبادرات من قبل الحلفاء على اهميتها وانما
ايضا هذه الزيارات تعتبر استثنائيه وهامه
في هذه المرحله وعلى ما يبدو انها تاتي
تلبيه لطلب لطلب علني لوزير الخارجيه
التركي الذي قال فيه ان كل ما جرى يعني
انه يجب التعامل مع الملف
انسانيا وليس سياسيا عبد الصمد في انتظار
المزيد من الانباء من افاد من المفترض ان
يعقد مؤتمر صحفي او يجري الحديث عن
تصريحات جديده تتعلق بالحصيله بعد قليل
حسب ما تم ابلاغنا وزاره الخارجيه التركيه
ايضا قامت بتحديث الارقام المتعلقه
بالطواقم الاجنبيه واكدت بان طواقم اكثر
من 72 دوله قد وصلت بالفعل واصبح هنالك
اكثر من عشره الاف اجنبي يعملون على الارض
الى جانب الطواقم التركيه
على الصعيد
يعني التصريحات والتصريحات المؤسسات
الرسميه وزاره التعليم وزير التعليم اجرى
مؤتمرا صحفيا اكد فيه على مساله تعليق
الجامعات حتى اشعار اخر او على الاقل حتى
الصيف لكي تفتح المدن الجامعيه او المساكن
الطلابيه
للايواء ويقول بان مدارس المناطق المنكوبه
ستبقى مغلقه حتى بدايه شهر اذار مارس
القادم اما بقيه المحافظات والمناطق
التركيه ايضا سيتم تعليقه عملها او عودتها
الى الدوام حتى الاسبوع اخيرا وزاره
الدفاع كذلك تؤكد بان المزيد من القوات
التابعه للجيش المزيد من القوات الامنيه
ترسل لتامين تلك المناطق وبانها
تقوم بتزويد تلك المناطق بالخيام عبر
المروحيات عبد الصمد فرح الزمان شوقي
مراسلات الجزيره من اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه افاد في انقره